Lucca Nate here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we're at seven
and a half thousand feet above sea level
in the Rocky Mountains and we are going
to be doing some winter survival camping
you already need
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the snow is so deep so wet every step is
so much work pulling Nathan on the sled
uphill through the deep snow is just too
much it's killing me but the snow is too
deep for him to walk through so I'm
fighting what I got to do is go up and
break trail and break trail back and try
to make it a little trench the width of
the toboggan and I can pull the toboggan
up and Nathan can walk behind it
toboggan but it's doubling my work cool
well I think I just found our campsite
there's a couple dead trees I can chop
up and use for firewood and building
materials the snows deep enough to help
me build my shelter all right let's
break trail back and get Nathan
this is very different winter campy and
what we did in Alaska a couple weeks ago
in Alaska he was about the cold the snow
was so light and powdery it was only
like 30 inches deep this is heavy wet
deep snow and is fighting us every step
of the way
so exhausted and I haven't even begun
building camp you tired buddy I'm
exhausted
you got a snow chair
[Music]
[Music]
well the stairs aren't exactly to code
but they'll do now I could be gettin old
but it seems to me that the worst part
is sleeping in a survival shelter is the
lumps on the ground so lay down in your
shelter a few times find some good
positions smooth it out make sure it's
not level get the rocks out of there
because it's a lot easier to fix it now
then in the middle of the night
all right I've done a lot of digging now
it's time to do a lot of chopping
there we go nice dead-ass pin right
there has some firewood we're at seven a
half thousand feet above sea level it's
almost a mile and a half it's just
harder to catch your breath
I find myself getting winded so easily
this log isn't that heavy but I have to
chop it up into smaller pieces because
if I pick up a 50 or 70 pound log I sink
so far down in the snow it's just
grueling to get anywhere
I have so much trouble with snowshoes
because they were a size 14 boot I
usually can't get the heel strap around
the boot so I'm constantly coming out of
them they just don't fit well big boy
problems
[Music]
well it's looking pretty good from this
angle but we gotta get inside and see if
we missed anything yeah hey big hole
right there and it's thin in the back
anything what do you think of this so
far here go inside yeah go check it out
no that's for sleeping look at that look
how far back in there you said is it
warmer it's back there if I'm gonna
sleep well tonight I need a good
insulator between me and the ground and
I'm gonna be using reindeer pelts
they've got these hollow hairs that are
excellent insulators and they're quite
thick and just it's analog Sharia thing
to sleep on now me and Nathan have used
these a few times in winter camping and
I just love it instead of sleeping bags
we're gonna be using this bison pelt
this thing's like six and a half feet by
seven and a half feet it's massive but
it is so thick and that should keep me
innate and plenty warm tonight oh I'm
exhausted but I'm excited I have not
slept in a snow cave since I was a
little kid we used to do it all the time
up in Alaska I was a kid now I need to
get a fire started and to do that I need
some dry pine it's not covered in snow
and ice only get the branches that don't
have snow on it when it's cold and
everything is caked and ice it takes a
lot of heat to get the wood to ignite so
grab it as much kindling as you can get
your hands on we went to all this effort
to find dry wood now we got to keep it
dry don't lay it in the snow don't
handle it
wet gloves find a place we'll touch as
little ice as possible
let it sit there while you get your fire
ready so I've got two of the big logs
stacked up to act as a little bit of a
heat reflector I'm putting a couple
other logs over here to thaw out just
need to start building a fire take some
of these relatively dry wood chips we're
gonna start with the fine stuff we want
this should make a nice crunchy sound if
it's bending too much it's green it's
gonna be a hard time lighting it I got
my favorite fire starter which is a bag
of shredded jute shredded jute is just
shredded twine I take a big ball of
twine and put it on a belt sander and it
just does this to it and it lights up
like crazy and if I'm not gonna use
matches my favorite thing to use is a
blast match it's just as ferrous rod and
a piece of steel you hold this tab down
and you just strike it like that it
makes a spark lights up really good
check this out
see that
you see lots of smoke like that means
you're smothering the fire but that's
kind of a necessary evil in cold weather
I put all this wood on it and let it
heat up before it'll catch fire nice
little no-match campfire
oh that's roaring well the Sun is
setting and the fire is roaring and
Nathan here is hungry so we need to make
some dinner but being the kind of
strange person that I am I didn't bring
a frying pan or a pot or any normal
stuff like that instead what I did is I
got this fifteen dollar aluminum shovel
which I knew I would need I stripped all
the paint off it and polished it and
then I seasoned it like you would
cast-iron using peanut oil and a butane
torch and then I baked it in my oven at
about 500 degrees for three hours so
this is a food-grade nonstick avalanche
shovel and we're going to cook fajitas
and quesadillas on this thing got the
shovel up against the fire drying and
letting it get nice and hot okay I made
this absolutely gorgeous fajita
marinated a and put it in this jar it's
basically orange juice lime juice cumin
paprika and worship sorcerer sauce I
made up some tomatillo salsa some
guacamole
yeah sour cream pico de gallo so nathan
is not much of a fajita man so for him
I'm going to make a quesadilla
yeah I need I need some kitchen space
here all right there we go all the
cabinet space you could ever want in the
kitchen now check that out is that a
good quesadilla
combine the meat in the vegetable I'll
warm up my tortilla here okay there's
not too bad I've got Nathan here with me
roaring fire a root beer and all the
fajitas I could eat huh like I said I
didn't bring any cooking utensils so I
just got a number-10 tin can and a bit
of wire and that's gonna be our kettle
for today I'm gonna put one reindeer
height on top of Nathan they're gonna
wrap up in the buffalo hide whoa there
you go buddy hi buddy you warm
hey you comfy huh all right you two go
to sleep buddy well Nathan's tucked in
under a big pile of animal hides and the
fire's doing its thing I'm just gonna
sit here for a little bit and relax I'm
gonna call it a night all right I'm
gonna try to get in here but Nathan's a
bit of a bed hog so we'll see if I can
fit my feet are sticking out a little
bit so that's a little worried but we'll
see how well this goes I'm warm right
now we'll see if it lasts I'll see you
guys
well good morning it's about 7:00 a.m.
and we're pretty toasty warm fire went
out long time ago I was hoping to start
the fire off the coals but it's looking
pretty dead I'm not feeling any heat but
let's root around see if we can't find
the hot spot one tiny little coal
got my tin can cooking pot make sure
it's bone-dry and we're gonna add peanut
oil to it we're just gonna use these
little dinner biscuits to come in the
can it doesn't really matter which brand
take them they're grubby dirty camping
hands make a little ring out of it
alright let's test the oil and see where
we're at there we go
that is a beautiful donut well it's
still hot a little oily dump it into a
bag of powdered sugar that is a very
delicious campfire doing it right there
you want to use my stick warm Donuts
that's not too bad we're doing it mmm
and these things are hot they just taste
absolutely delicious just like a
homemade donut but once they cool down
they kind of taste like a biscuit itself
this is a food enjoyed fresh and hot you
got a little white powder on your nose
there that's how he stays so active his
camping trips always follow the same
pattern the first day is so hectic I'm
chopping wood I'm building shelters all
this stuff second day just relaxing and
cooking food like that all right now
we're gonna make lunch and for that
we're going to make corn dogs what I
have here is corn dog batter it's really
simple to make this is actually the
recipe based off of the famous corn dogs
at Disneyland it's basically one part
cornmeal one part flour a couple
teaspoons of baking soda honey and sugar
and touch of salt it's kind of a sweet
batter stick a hot dog on a
stick oh oh look at that look at that is
that not a gorgeous corndog all right
we'll just let it sit there and cool for
a little bit just give it a bite right
there on the corner with yeah you kind
of like that so you know what we got to
do before we leave we've got to burn all
of this wood including the roof you got
to burn the roof down what what because
it's such a high risk area for forest
fires in the summertime we don't want to
leave any piles of dead wood laying
around including the boughs that we used
for our roof
Nathan you ready to go down the mountain
yeah well it took us like an hour or so
to break trail uphill Nathan's gonna do
it in seconds well we hope you guys
enjoyed watching this video as much as
we enjoyed making it unfortunately
YouTube's disabled comments last year
because my kids are in the video so if
you want to leave a comment or suggest a
different type of video you want to see
follow us on Facebook leave a comment we
really appreciate it
but thanks for watching and have a great
day if you like this video don't forget
to check out the outdoor boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
Subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watch
[Music]